I hate saying goodbyes not really
goodbye life hasn't always been easy for
you Alex and it looks like things are
going to get even more complicated from
here on out you never planned for your
sister Hayley to join the green house
Academy but she ended up being recruited
by the Ravens and you were on opposite
teams for way too long but choosing
between your sister and your Clubhouse
was the least of your worries
we love Netflix tween drama series green
house Academy but we couldn't help but
notice that some scenes don't always add
up from Brookes recasting to basketball
game interruptions to questionable
school curriculums we've got all the
shows loose ends lined up for you keep
watching to find out why the bomb
debacle at the end of season two just
didn't make sense the break-in in season
1 episode 2 Judy hires Kyle to delete
files off of Carter woods at computer
Carter is sleeping on the couch during
the home invasion Carter doesn't blink
an eye when the intruder points a
flashlight into his face and he doesn't
move a muscle when Kyle drops a picture
frame right at his feet but Carter does
wake up when kyle closes the front door
on his way out that doesn't make much
sense now does it no need to brag in
that very same episode Kyle meets up
with Judy in an underground parking
garage
Judy seems impressed that Kyle deleted
all the files while Carter was fast
asleep a few feet away from him Kyle
brags about his credentials it's almost
like he forgot that he dropped a frame
and almost got busted nice one Kyle
school curriculums you would think that
a special boarding school designed to
groom future leaders would have a very
impressive curriculum but in season two
episode 2 we find out that the students
are still struggling to learn slope in
math class aren't the students supposed
to be like 17 year old geniuses or
something
Jackie's sketchbook we max accidentally
spill something on Jackie's bag
he ruins her notebook but instead of
fessing up and offering to repair it he
takes it out of the trash and sneaks off
with it we couldn't help but chuckle at
this scene max took the notebook from
the trash and hid it under his shirt in
the most obvious way possible take
medication in season 1 episode 3 Brooke
catches Daniel drinking something
strange out of his locker she steals one
of her dad's keys to open Daniels locker
at the end of the episode and it turns
out that Daniel is taking swigs from a
painkiller bottle the medication is
labeled I view flips pin which doesn't
really exist in real life this seemed
didn't make a lot of sense and what's
worse is that Brookes father who is the
headmaster of greenhouse doesn't do a
good job at keeping his keys locked up
the train game
Suzanne McGill has a funny way of
teaching her students at the greenhouse
Academy but if there's an exercise that
had us laughing in no time
it was the train game Suzanne gave her
students the choice of letting a train
crash into a stalled car on the tracks
it's gonna crash into the car and kill
everyone who sits in it killing five
innocent people or redirecting the train
into a brick wall killing 20 passengers
the students were asked to make a
decision but we couldn't help but wonder
why the people in the car simply didn't
exit it to make matters worse they were
in a convertible different handwriting
in season 1 episode 10 we find out that
Ryan has been keeping a secret from
Carter for years she left him a letter
in case she didn't make it back from her
space trip but someone else got to it
first we see Ryan right open only in
case I don't come back on an envelope
but when we see the letter again the
sentence is written in different
handwriting on top of this Ryan chose to
leave her a very important letter where
anyone could find it which wasn't
exactly the smartest thing to do
basketball interruptions coach Davies
isn't someone who messes around
especially not in the middle of a game
but for some strange reason cheerleaders
and spectators are allowed to interrupt
the players mid game we
seen this happen on more than one
account like when Sophie stopped Alex in
the middle of the game to tell him that
she saw Leo and Haley in the driveway
a typical coach would bench their player
for putting a game on hold for social
matters the cave bomb in season 2
episode 11 Kyle explains that the bomb
will be strong enough to wipe out the
caves and olive green house Academy
Haley Ryan and Marcus are stuck in a
cave with a bomb that is seconds away
from detonating Leo and Daniel managed
to get into the cave and take the bomb
outside with them they throw it into the
air and it explodes throwing them back
it's hard to believe that a bomb
powerful enough to destroy over six
miles of land didn't completely
annihilate everyone near the caves and
beyond instead a small explosion was
shown and Leo and Daniel made it out
alive the new Brooke Brooke Osmond was
portrayed by Grace and Ian for the first
two seasons but she left the show to
join the TV series the village
which led to producers having to recast
her role so now Brooke is played by
Danica yarosh and we're still having a
hard time adjusting who is your favorite
character from green house Academy which
couple are you shipping sound off in the
comments thanks for watching hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you next time on the themes
[Music]
you